[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAROLYN ALBURGER: I'm really
excited to be here today,
sitting with Andy Ricker, who
is a known Thai food expert.
He is a big part
of actually pushing
our American consciousness
around Thai food,
and understanding of it
beyond pad thai, green curry,
the things you see in so many
restaurants here in America.
He has Pok Poks
in Portland and--
ANDY RICKER: New York.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
New York restaurants.
He has won a James Beard
award, which is hard to get,
so I hear.
ANDY RICKER: Two.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Two?
Two?
ANDY RICKER: Be accurate.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
In which years?
[LAUGHTER]
ANDY RICKER: Well, I won
for best chef one year
and I won for
writing another year.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Oh, nice.
I didn't know about
the writing one.
Wow, so many talents.
And you've published your
second cookbook this year,
which is why we're
all here today.
It's called "The Drinking
Food of Thailand".
Before we dive
into that, I wanted
to ask you guys in the audience
quickly, how many of you
have been to Thailand?
Nice.
ANDY RICKER: Wow,
a bunch of you.
That's great.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: And then how
many have been to a Pok Pok?
Very cool.
ANDY RICKER: The same people.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDY RICKER: Except for you.
OK.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Not super surprising.
Well, great.
So there are some people that
aren't fully acquainted, maybe,
with your restaurants,
so I thought
it might be good for you
to dive into your expertise
and how you got here.
You don't look like you're Thai.
ANDY RICKER: No.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Am I right?
OK.
ANDY RICKER: It's true.
You're very right about that.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So
how did we get here?
ANDY RICKER: So the
question, how did I
start a Thai restaurant?
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Your journey
to becoming a Thai food expert,
basically.
ANDY RICKER: Well,
first of all, I
want to say that I don't
consider myself an expert.
I consider myself
more of a student.
And how I got here
was by traveling.
Essentially, that's
the way, in my opinion,
that's the best way to live.
If you're curious
about something
that is a living culture, or
living art form or cuisine
or something that comes
from somewhere else,
you go there and check it out.
I went there initially as
a backpacker in the '80s,
and I wasn't really
looking for anything
except for a good time.
Which I had.
And I went again
in the early '90s.
'92, to be exact.
And I had a really good friend
of mine who was living there
who had married a local woman
who worked at the university
as a professor.
And they were-- she
is from Chiang Mai,
and that's where
he had settled in.
So they introduced me
to the local cuisine
while I was there, which was--
they introduced me to
some seasonal dishes.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: I
didn't really realize
that there was such a
thing as seasonal food when
it comes to Thai food,
because my experience was
much like a lot of other
folks in America, which
is that you get your experience
by going to a Thai restaurant
here.
And for many, many years--
things are changing a lot now.
Over the last 10 years,
things have changed a lot.
But during that time
it was basically
the same menu wherever you
went and it never changed.
So being in Chiang Mai
and being introduced
to a dish that was local,
seasonal, regional,
was really kind of shocking.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
What was that dish?
Do you remember?
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, I mean,
I've told this story probably
a million times, but it's
a dish called gang het pok.
Het-top is a type of mushroom.
It looks like a puffball.
It's kind of really
dark brown, it
has kind of a bitter taste to
it, very earthy and bitter,
but it's really
prized wild mushroom.
So right around
March, April, they
start coming up in the
forest and people--
in Chiang Mai, I lived in
a small village about 20
kilometers north of Chiang Mai.
And during het-top
season, if you
try to go to the
market in the village,
as soon as the het-top
start popping up,
all of a sudden all
the shops are closed.
You're like, where is everybody?
Why?
And they're like, oh, they're
off gathering het-top,
because het-top gets
200 baht a kilo or more.
And, you go get them for
free out of the forest. .
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: So they're
really highly prized,
but they only come up
for about a month, month
and a half out of the year.
And when they come up,
they make some dishes
using that particular mushroom.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Amazing.
ANDY RICKER: And
so that was the way
that I first connected
with the idea
that there was something
regional, local, seasonal--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Ephemeral.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, like just
like regional American food
or Spanish food or Italian
food or French food
or anywhere where there's
a regional, seasonal type
cuisine.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: And from there
you just kind of got hooked,
and you kept going
back to Thailand
and just became a real
true student of the food,
sounds like.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, I started
going back again and again
and again.
And at first, it
was very tentative,
because I couldn't
speak the language.
I couldn't read-- still
can't read the language--
and I didn't really
know that much about it,
so I was relying on
my friends to guide
me, and friends of friends.
I was just spending
all my time in markets,
walking around looking
at stuff, slowly
learning how to speak the
language, until I started
to gain enough knowledge that
I could kind of start really
delving into it.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
And at that time,
what were you doing for work?
Were you a cook, were you--
ANDY RICKER: OK,
so initially, I was
working as a cook or a
sous chef or whatever.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: In Portland?
ANDY RICKER: In Portland,
yeah, it was mostly Portland
at this point.
And then I started being
a painting contractor.
I was a painting contractor
for about eight years.
And what that
allowed me to do was
I'd work really
hard from the spring
through the end of summer
into the holiday season,
and then work would dry up
over the holiday season, which
was perfect, so I
could go to Thailand
and hang out for a
couple of months.
And so that happened
every year, and that
was where I really
started digging in,
during the mid-90s up
to the early 2000s.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So
let's talk about the book.
The title is interesting,
"Drinking Food of Thailand",
not "Thai Drinking Food".
ANDY RICKER: You know what?
I actually had a
little bit of a battle
with the editor over that.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Tell us about it.
ANDY RICKER: OK, so--
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Tell
us about the fight.
ANDY RICKER: It
wasn't a major fight.
The first, we had a huge
fight about the photograph
on the first book.
This was-- so the title of
it is [SPEAKING THAI],, which
means food with whiskey.
[SPEAKING THAI]
And "The Drinking
Food of Thailand"
is, instead of "Thai
Drinking Food",
when you say-- when
I think of Thai food,
I'm thinking of the
center of Thailand.
Thai people, and they're
the dominant culture.
But they're not the
only culture there.
There's the people of the
north, the [INAUDIBLE],,
and then there's subgroups
of ethnic groups, Yong,
[? Hmong, ?] that type of thing.
If you look back far
enough in history,
you see that the Thai people are
the most dominant culture now,
but they weren't always.
And the language of the north
is different from the language
of the center is different from
the language of the northeast ,
which is where mostly Lao
and Khmer people live.
The climates are very different.
Staple rices are different.
The very south of Thailand
has its own culture, language,
and food.
And so when you say Thai
food to a Thai person,
say we're in Chiang Mai
and you say to your friend,
you want to go out
and eat, and they
say, what do you want to
eat, if you say Thai food,
you're talking about
central Thai food.
You're going to go eat--
or you want to eat
Issan food, you
want to go find a
northeastern restaurant.
Or if you want to
eat Thai-Yai food,
you're going to go eat
Shan Thai-Yai food,
it's not Thai food.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: So I
know it seems petty,
but I kind of went to the mat
with them, because they wanted
to say "Thai Drinking Food",
I'm like, no, really, it's not,
because we're going the
country a little bit
and cherry-picking things.
And some of the food
that's featured in here
has nothing to do with Thai,
central Thai food at all.
So that was important to me
to make that distinction.
In a lot of ways, that's
kind of what I've attempted
to do with the restaurants and
the books since the beginning,
is kind of point out that
Thailand isn't a monoculture.
Though if you ask somebody
from Thailand who's from Issan,
they still feel Thai.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: But there's a
back history to everything
that's not apparent.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Got it.
ANDY RICKER: It helps
to define the food.
It helps people understand the
food itself and how to eat it,
and how it fits into the
context of the culture.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
So I'm guessing
that you can't get any
of this food in any
of your restaurants.
ANDY RICKER: No, you can.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: You
can, absolutely.
We have a restaurant in
Portland called the Whiskey Soda
Lounge, which is dedicated
to this food, actually.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Amazing.
So if people are just
picking up this book
for the first time,
which I'm guessing
a lot of people in the
audience here will be doing,
is there a good icebreaker
recipe in the book?
A nice starting place?
ANDY RICKER: There is.
Probably one of
my favorite dishes
in the genre is
something called yam
met mamuang himaphaan,
which is long--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: What page?
ANDY RICKER: It should
be pretty early on.
It's in salads.
But essentially it's a very long
way of saying cashew nut salad.
So really, it's
very, very simple.
You just roast cashew
nuts, either dry or in oil,
and then you sprinkle salt,
scallions, and chilies
or top of it.
And then you just
eat it with a spoon.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
That looks easy.
ANDY RICKER: It's about
as easy as it gets.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
This is a recipe?
ANDY RICKER: It's a
recipe, believe it or not.
And that picture-- you see
the picture that's taken.
I should talk a little bit--
show them the picture, yeah.
So that was taken
at a karaoke in--
I'm trying to remember where
we were when we took this--
I think we were in Ang
Thong, north of Bangkok,
when we took that, at a hotel.
They had like a karaoke slash
stage shows place cabaret.
And it's the table
number 35, there,
in case you didn't notice.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: I see that.
So cool.
So these are pictures
directly from your travels.
ANDY RICKER: So what we
did was we went around
and we took photographs
of the food--
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
There's the karaoke bar.
ANDY RICKER: That's
a different place.
That's in Bangkok at
a Isaan-style cabaret.
We went to these
various different types
of drinking establishments
and we shot the dishes there.
They'd bring it, put it
on the table, and bam,
we'd shoot it with a
hard flash to make it
so that the vibe should
feel kind of like you're
out somewhere at night.
But that dish
itself is something
that you can find almost
anywhere where you're going
to go out and go drinking.
Side of the road, anywhere
where they can cook stuff.
It's such an easy thing to do.
And people love it so much.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yeah.
ANDY RICKER: And it's kind
of-- if you think about it,
it's kind of perfect
drinking food.
It's hot, it's nutty
and salty, crunchy,
and it goes great
with beer and whiskey.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So
like a really good thing
to just throw together if
you're having people over
and you want--
ANDY RICKER: You're watching
the football game or whatever.
Yeah.
It looks really dopey
simple, almost lazy,
but it's one of the most
delicious things in the book.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Very cool.
ANDY RICKER: Really good.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: How about
something that is like
more labor-intensive, maybe
a little more daunting,
but you just think it's so
amazing, you're so proud of it,
and it's worth the
effort for people
to maybe spend a whole day
finding the ingredients
and cooking it?
ANDY RICKER: So one of the
premises of the book was,
first of all, was to go
out and shoot it and then
do the recipes later.
The other one was to have
a little bit of discovery
during the process
of making the book,
like trying to find a new
dish or some interesting way
of cooking that I hadn't had
before in the process of making
the book.
So there's this
one dish called sii
khrong muu tai naam, which means
pork ribs cooked underwater.
And it's kind of a punny thing.
Essentially, the trick
is that you pound up
a paste of aromatics and chilies
and garlic and stuff like that,
and then you mix it either with
chicken wings or with pork ribs
and you put it into a pot with
maybe just a little bit of oil,
but not much.
And then you fire it up and
you put a bowl of ice water
on top of it.
And the ice water seals
the top of the pot.
And as the moisture from
the cooking paste and meat
and everything, hits
the bottom of the bowl,
it condenses and drops
back down into the pot.
Now, how did I find this?
In the weirdest place,
I was in Slovenia.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Not Thailand.
ANDY RICKER: Not Thailand.
But I was traveling with a good
friend of mine, this guy named
David Thompson, who is a really
well-known Thai chef, also,
obviously, not Thai, and his
sous chef, [? Pot, ?] said hey,
have you ever heard of
this dish, tai naam?
And I was like, no, I
never heard of that before.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yeah.
ANDY RICKER: And he
explained it to me.
So when I got to Thailand,
I started looking into it
and I asked a few people around.
It turns out it's kind an Isaan
thing, a northeastern thing.
And I didn't have a recipe.
So I just kind of looked
around on the internet
to see if there was
anybody who was making it.
I couldn't find anybody
in Chiang Mai area
that actually made it.
It's kind of-- I think it's
more kind of like something
that people do at home.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: So I talked
to some friends from Isaan.
They're like, oh, yeah,
yeah, it's this whole thing.
So it was described,
like they described
the various different things
you would put into it,
so I just kind of tried it.
And it took me probably
about six or eight
times to get it right.
But it's a really
interesting technique.
It's a delicious dish.
It kind of smothers
the meat in this paste
and kind of sticks to the
ribs and it's really, really
spicy, really savory,
and if you want
to impress somebody with
your cooking skills,
it's a good one.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
That's really cool.
That story is so
interesting, too.
So you never actually
found someone
cooking it in their home?
ANDY RICKER: No,
I never found it.
No, I didn't.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: But
you know it exists,
that people were making it.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, and
I talked to some people,
some Isaan people about it,
and they were like, oh yeah,
we used to do that
with a whole chicken.
Some people would
take a whole chicken
and chop it up and
do it, or some people
say we would just
do it with wings.
But I thought it would
be really good with pork
because it would
allow it to cook
for a longer period of time.
So anyway.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Smart.
Wow.
That's very cool.
ANDY RICKER: That's the
chef-y bit of me coming out.
I normally don't exercise that.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Well, you
are a chef, so we expect that.
ANDY RICKER: That's
what they tell me.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
So I know there's
a lot of maybe hard to find
ingredients in this book.
I would love for you to
talk about some of those.
Maybe--
ANDY RICKER: Here, no.
I think you guys are tight here.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
In San Francisco?
ANDY RICKER: There's very few
things that are in this book
that you can't get in a
good southeast Asian market
in San Francisco.
This particular book.
There's a few things.
Like occasionally, like for
one of the recipes for larb,
there's a few spices
that are really
difficult to get
a hold of that you
have to really hunt it down.
I found them in New York
through a purveyor there,
and I bet if there's
anybody from Chiang Mai that
lives here, or
northern Thailand,
you probably would be able to
find a few of these things.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: There's
one called Makhwaen,
which is kind of a black prickly
ash, relative of prickly ash.
It's relatively hard to find.
There's no real substitute for.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: What
does that tastes like?
ANDY RICKER: Kind of
like black prickly ash.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Delicious.
I was thinking of just the
numbing, spicy peppercorns.
ANDY RICKER: It's
peppery, but it
doesn't have that numbing,
that really numbing flavor
that Sichuan peppercorns have.
And it's kind of got a bitter,
very distinctive flavor that
is not entirely unlike
Sichuan peppercorn,
but also not quite
like it either.
I think that that
particular type of tree,
I think there's a lot
of different varieties,
a bunch of different variety.
There's green, red,
black, and then
a whole bunch of other stuff.
The trees are amazing.
The trees for the Sichuan--
I don't know if you've
ever seen them before,
but the trunks have these
crazy spikes on them.
So whoever decided to climb one
to get the stuff out of there
the first time was
a real daredevil.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: A
real hero of cooking.
ANDY RICKER: It might not
have lived to tell the tale.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Are there
things that you have to order
online?
Like certain things that you--
ANDY RICKER: Again, really, I
think if you look around here,
you're going to find
everything you need.
Perhaps if you live
in Kansas City,
you might have to order stuff
online or use frozen things.
But here I think
you're pretty good.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Awesome.
So how about, if
people are going
to get this book for someone
for Christmas or as a gift,
is there some kind of
a companion gift you
think might be good with it?
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, a bottle of
whiskey or six-pack of beer,
I think, is probably the
best companion for it.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: That would
be the most festive, for sure.
ANDY RICKER: And
you probably want
to get it for somebody
who likes to drink.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yes.
Actually, I'm
interested to know--
ANDY RICKER: Mortar and pestle.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: A
mortar and pestle?
ANDY RICKER: I
mean, really, it's
really difficult to make
this food without a mortar
and pestle.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: I don't really
know how to do it without it.
So what you want is a
granite mortar and pestle.
You should have one of those
anyway, if you're into cooking.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So where
do you find one of those?
Do they have it at
Williams Sonoma?
ANDY RICKER: They might have
like a little crappy one.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right, I
know, because you said granite,
so I'm like--
ANDY RICKER: You want to go
to a southeast Asian market,
and they typically have them.
They range in size
from this to this.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER:
Typically you can find
some that are about that big,
and try to get the biggest one
you can find, because it's
not going to be that big.
And you can make
curry pastes in it.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Does almost
every recipe require that tool?
ANDY RICKER: Almost every.
Not all.
The yam met mamuang
himaphaan doesn't.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
Noted.
So that's just kind of
like a part of the pomp--
not the pomp and circumstance--
but the preparation
of most Thai dishes,
is that people whip out
their mortar and pestle and
they're just smashing together
flavors.
ANDY RICKER: I can give you
a story about that, too.
So the name of the
restaurant, Pok Pok,
is the sound of the
pestle hitting a mortar.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: So the way that
I came up with that name
was many years ago, I was on
the diesel railcar from Khorat
back to Bangkok.
And I'd come from all
the way up in Chiang Mai
and I'd come all the
way down through Isaan
and ended up in Khorat
or Ubon Ratchathani,
and I went there to
eat larb, duck larb.
And I was on the rail
car back to Bangkok
and I was sitting in
third class because I
was a broke-ass backpacker.
And there were some folks there
who were workers from Isaan who
were going back to Bangkok
after the holidays,
and we started talking.
And they said, why are you here?
Why did you come to Khorat?
Because at the time,
there were very few--
there were some ex-pats
there but not many
tourists, even though
it's one of the biggest
metropolitan areas
in all of Thailand.
Huge, the second
or third largest
in all of Thailand by size.
And I said, well,
I want to eat food.
And I named a few of the dishes.
And they're like, oh,
you like to eat that.
Can you cook too?
And I was like, yeah,
I can cook some things.
And I said, yes, can you cook?
And he said yeah,
pok, pok, pok, pok,
making the motion of the
pestle hitting the mortar.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: And
you were like, I got it.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah.
But it was very much an a-ha
moment, because in his mind,
he connected the idea of cooking
with the mortar and pestle.
That was immediate.
He didn't kind of go like--
like that or-- he
was like pok, pok,
it was mortar and
pestle right away.
So it is literally--
there is no way to cook
Thai food without a mortar
and pestle that I know of,
that is going to give you
results that are anywhere near
what I think they should be.
You can use-- some people use
blenders or food processors
or stuff, but there's
something about it
that's not quite right right.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: As far as
drinking goes, I noticed--
I was skimming
through the book, I
noticed you talk about a lot of
things that you can't get here,
like some kind of Thai beer
that I've never heard of,
rice whiskey.
What do you recommend that
people drink with this food
here in San Francisco?
I'm guessing it's not going
to be a Sonoma Cabernet
or something like that.
ANDY RICKER: Well, you can
drink whatever you want.
Wine's actually
started to become
quite popular in Thailand
with the upper middle class.
It's kind of a luxury item and
kind of a big face thing to do,
is buy wine.
There's actually a couple
of wineries in Thailand now.
They're not good, but
that's to be expected.
It's not quite grape
growing country.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: So beer
is probably the thing
you're going to have the
easiest time drinking--
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
That makes sense.
ANDY RICKER: --using
as the main booze.
But Thailand is a rice
liquor country, historically.
Beer started out as
a luxury item there.
For a lot of folks, I'd say
the vast majority of the poorer
folks who live in
the countryside,
it's still a luxury item.
So it was introduced to
Thailand back probably
60 or 70 years ago,
maybe a little longer,
but it was imported from
Germany or Holland or something
like that.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Which brands?
ANDY RICKER: Back then,
I couldn't tell you.
I don't know.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Because now it's
mostly the Chang and
the Singha, right?
ANDY RICKER: And
there's a story there.
It's actually in the book.
I know this guy named
Nick Bhirom Bhakdi.
He's the grandson of
the founder of Singha.
And the Singha family is--
the Bhirom Bhakdi family
is very high [INAUDIBLE]
family in Thailand.
They're very, very rich.
They own Singha.
They're connected
to the royal family.
All that kind of stuff.
And Nick's grandfather used
to own a ferry company that
went across the
Chao Phraya river
from Bangkok to Bangkok Noi.
And he started
seeing the motorcars
coming into play,
and then bridges
being built across
the river, and he
could see that his business
was probably not going
to be as strong in the future.
So he started looking
for ways to diversify,
and he had studied in
Germany, and his brother
was in Germany as
well, studying,
and come back as an engineer.
Sent his brother back
to Germany to learn
how to be a brewmaster.
His brother went back, learned
how to be a brewmaster,
came back, and they started
brewing beer, for which
there was almost no market.
So he spent, I think,
the first few years
that they were
open, several years,
they brewed like four or five
different brands of beer.
And he went and he'd go to
towns and he put on a movie
night, give people
beer to taste.
Out of the five or six
different formulas they had,
the one that stuck
was the Singha,
which is a kind
of a tiger-like--
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
A little bit sweet.
ANDY RICKER: Well, the singha
is a mythological creature
and it--
kind of tigery.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
It's a griffin, right?
ANDY RICKER: But
the beer itself--
yeah, kind of.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
It looks like one.
ANDY RICKER: The beer
itself was whatever.
It was the one
that people liked.
So that's what they stuck
with and they got rid
of all the other crap.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Smart.
It's not rocket science.
ANDY RICKER: And then they did
a couple of really sneaky moves,
which was to kind of
petition the crown
to kind of make it
difficult for other people
to compete with them.
So that's why there's only
a couple of beers left.
There's some really
arcane laws there,
where it's basically
counter to what
you would think it would be.
You can only
commercially produce beer
if you produce a huge
amount at a time.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: And sell a
huge amount at a time.
So if you produce less than
that amount, you can't sell it.
You can sell it in
your own establishment,
but you can't sell
it commercially,
which has been really
problematic for the people who
are into craft beer in Thailand,
because they can either
import stuff at great expense,
or they can they can make it
but they can't really
sell it outside
of their own little pub.
So they've had a kind of a
lock on the beer industry
there for decades,
decades, and decades.
Slowly starting to change now.
But even then,
beer was a luxury.
And today, say you're
working on a rice farm
or you're working in a
factory, your median wage
there is probably around--
I think they'd pumped it up
to closer to 500 baht a day
and then they just cut the
minimum wage, recently,
back down to like 310 baht
a day or 270 baht a day.
So it's possible--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Is that
because the president
died, right?
ANDY RICKER: It's because the
military took over and the--
it's long, we won't get
into the politics of it.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Outside
the scope of the talk.
ANDY RICKER: There was
some populist shit that
was going on for a long
time that kind of got axed,
and that was one of the
things that was very populist.
The upshot of it is
that if you're a worker
and you're making 300 baht a
day, which is roughly $9 a day,
and you go to 7-Eleven
and you buy a beer,
it might cost you 100 baht
for a big bottle of beer,
95 to 100 baht for a
large bottle of beer.
But you can also go down
to the local Lao Khao stand
and you can buy a whole bottle
of rice whiskey for 80 baht.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: That's when I
was reading about in the book.
ANDY RICKER: Right.
You can-- one bottle of
beer gets nobody fucked up,
and one bottle of whiskey
gets four people fucked up.
So it's a matter of economics.
Plus it's a rice
culture going back
hundreds and hundreds of years.
And so people are
used to drinking that.
So that was-- a lot
of these things were
kind of made with that in mind.
Now if you want to try to
replicate that here, go
and buy the cheapest
crappiest shochu you can find.
And that approximates
what kind of a crappy
Lao Khao, or [? white ?]
whiskey will be like.
Same thing.
It's distilled from
rice typically,
unless it's distilled
from barley or-- just look
for a rice-based shochu
that's not too expensive,
and you can get an idea of
what Lao Khao tastes like.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Sounds delicious.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDY RICKER: It's fantastic.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So
when I was in Thailand,
I remember people telling me
that the beer was unregulated
and that there was amphetamines
in some of the Chang.
ANDY RICKER: That's a total lie.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK,
I just had to ask.
I know that's off topic,
but I was just curious.
ANDY RICKER: I think what
they're talking about
is that there's rumors
out there, that I'm not
sure whether
they're true or not,
that the alcohol content isn't
regulated from batch to batch.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yes, I
remember hearing that too.
ANDY RICKER: So that
sometimes you get the beer
and it's stronger than others.
I don't know that
that's true anymore.
I think that the beer making
in Thailand is very modernized
and there's a lot of
controls and stuff like that.
I doubt that's true anymore.
But Chang, the
thing is that when
Chang came out and started
competing with Singha,
they did two things.
They made it cheaper and
they made it stronger.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: So that was
their-- and they made it sweeter
and that was why Chang got
really, really popular.
And Singha battled that by
producing Leo beer which
also is a little stronger,
cheaper, but not as sweet,
a little lighter.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right, so
it's diversifying a little bit.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah.
And that happened a while back.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: All right.
So I'm kind of also
curious-- this doesn't
have to do with the book, but
I'm wondering, as a traveler,
how you avoid tourist traps.
I'm sure you're
pretty good at that.
How do you make sure
you get the food
the people in the
country are eating
and not the crappy
diluted version of that?
ANDY RICKER: I think it's
important to not think about it
so much as, if I go
off the beaten track,
I'm going to find
the true stuff,
because unless you read Thai
and you know what you're looking
for, like you actually
know what to look for,
like you know the
names of the dish,
you know where you're
going to find it,
you know what the good one is
going to be, you can read Thai
or you're with somebody
who can read Thai, that
trusts you're going to
be able to eat the food,
you're going have a very
difficult time finding anything
at all.
And likewise, if you're in
the middle of a tourist trap,
there's always some
good food there,
because the people who work
in the tourist traps eat too.
So if you go to, say,
MBK, Mahboonkrong,
is the most famous
mall, even though it's
kind of the oldest
and crappiest one now.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
And where is that?
ANDY RICKER: It's
near Siam Square
in the center of Bangkok.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: OK.
ANDY RICKER: And you
go inside, there's
all these food courts there.
And some are quite flashy,
and there's the place
where all the tourists go.
But there's also a food
court on the fifth floor
in the back corner that's run
by Isaan folks, that's actually
really bang-on, hardcore,
country-style Isaan food
right in the mall.
And that's where all the people
that work there go to eat.
So you don't have to go off the
beaten path to find good food.
You have to be willing to
dig in and see what's there.
And the best advice I can give
is go to where the people who
are working where--
like you go to the airport,
you go to Suvarnabhumi Airport,
you go down to the bottom
level where the taxicabs are,
and you go all
the way to the end
and there's a
cafeteria in there.
There's a food court.
That's where all the people
that work in the airport
go for lunch.
And it's actually really good.
Same story at Don Muang.
There's a place there
that all the workers
go that's really good.
So you can be on
Patpong Road, or you
could go to Khao
San or something,
you're still going
to find good food.
You just have to look
for it a little bit.
Does that makes sense?
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Yeah, I mean you just
have to kind of watch where--
you have to pay attention.
You have to have your
eyes open and watch
where people that live
there are going, basically.
ANDY RICKER: Now, the good
thing is that nowadays there is
such a thing as the internet.
So you can go on the internet
and go, best food in this area.
And there's going to be some
English-speaking local or
English-speaking ex-pat
that lives in the area who's
mapped all these places.
And you can find
them because there'll
be pictures of the
damn place, there'll
be a pin dropped on it.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Do
you feel like it's
getting harder, though, as
Thailand gets more touristy?
I know that tourism has
really exploded there
in the past eight
years, probably.
ANDY RICKER: I don't
know that tourism
is at fault with the
changing food culture there.
I think it's mostly
having to do with--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Globalization?
ANDY RICKER: Yeah,
globalization, modernization,
the existence of a middle class,
speaking about urban areas.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: You know, the
tastes of the Thai people
are changing, but you
can still find things
made as they were decades ago.
Still can.
Still look a little bit hard.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: The
question of authenticity
is one that I know
comes up a lot.
I feel like it makes
sense to talk about that.
ANDY RICKER: Sure.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
It's definitely been
in the media a
lot lately, people
debating the authenticity
of certain foods.
And I'm sure that you get
asked this question a lot.
But how do you deal
with naysayers or people
that challenge the
authenticity of your cuisine?
ANDY RICKER: Well, that's easy.
We don't claim any
authenticity, to start with.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: It helps.
ANDY RICKER: Part of--
when Pok Pok opened,
I banished the word
authentic and traditional
from the vocabulary,
because they're such
loaded words that
mean different things
to different people.
The absurdity of authenticity.
You talk to any
chef, anybody who's
a cook, who has any
knowledge of food ways
and that kind of thing, and
the notion of authenticity
just kind of goes
out the window.
Authentic is what you
experience as authentic.
So if your mom makes, say,
[? tom ?] [? kha ?] [? kai ?]
one way, to you, that's
the authentic way
because that's what you
grew up eating, tasting,
and you've been told by
everybody in your family
that's the best version.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: Meanwhile,
the dude up the street,
their mom made it too, and
he's been told the same thing.
As far as he's concerned,
his version is authentic.
So no matter-- if I was to
come along and go here's
authentic whatever, people
would say that's not authentic,
because I know what authentic
is, because my mom's Thai
and she made it this way.
You like, well, I don't know.
That's why we don't
use the word authentic.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Right but do you
think there's
something to be said
for the way in which you
approach a cuisine that is not
your own?
ANDY RICKER: I think that
doesn't have anything
to do with authenticity.
I think that that has to
do with something else.
For me--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Respect.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah.
I think authenticity is a
different subject from that.
The way that you
approach cuisine,
if you were going
to learn about it,
you just learn as
much as you can,
and you don't assume
that you know anything.
You don't assume that you've
learned the gold standard.
You don't assume that
the way you're doing it
is the right way.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: What
are you still trying
to learn about Thai food?
ANDY RICKER: Everything.
I mean, the more I know--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Are
there certain regions--
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, the south.
The south of Thailand is
a giant mystery to me.
I've spent some time there.
I have the basic idea
of what it's about.
I probably have maybe a little
bit more experience there
than most people.
But by far, I feel like it's
a whole mysterious new cuisine
that I could spend
a lifetime learning.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Do you plan on it?
Or are you more
interested in the regions
you're already specializing in?
ANDY RICKER: No, I plan on
spending more time there.
I was just there shooting some
video with the Thai Tourism
Authority, and we just
ate some amazing food.
And it's a totally
different flavor palate
than the north,
different ingredients,
and different traditions
that it comes from,
different way people think
about the food, the way
that they eat is different.
And I look forward to
learning as much as I can.
I mean, I've got--
hopefully I'll live
long enough that I can
delve a little bit into that.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So
what are your goals
right now, professionally?
Like, do you want to
basically just retire
in Thailand as
quickly as possible?
ANDY RICKER: I'm just trying
to keep my head low right now.
It's kind of a jungle out there
in the restaurant industry.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Explain that.
In what ways?
ANDY RICKER: We're going to
have to start all over again
and be here for hours.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Are you talking
about just the physical
opening of a restaurant?
ANDY RICKER: No, I can open
restaurants all day long.
I can find a restaurant,
design it, do the menu,
get it open, no problem.
It's the managing
of them once you've
got it open that's problematic.
We've got a huge
problem in the industry
with wage income disparity
between the front and back
of the house, with the
front of the house taking
the lion's share
of the money, back
of the house trailing behind.
Meanwhile, restaurants work on
a very, very thin margin, very
thin, and there's no way
in our current system
of tipping to reconcile those
two things without a sea
change in the way that
the dining public looks
at restaurants.
It's an extremely
difficult problem
and nobody knows
what the answer is.
The more people try-- like
people like Danny Meyer,
who's an industry leader,
tries to change things,
he started getting sued
by people for trying
to do the right thing.
So it's very, very fraught,
and there's a lot of emotion
around it.
There's not a whole lot
of facts being used to--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Disseminate
information to the public.
ANDY RICKER: It's a
very difficult thing
to educate the public on.
There's a bunch of
things that people
think are true that
aren't true that
are-- it's very
difficult to talk about
because they're political.
So yeah, it's just not a
great-- like if any of you
are thinking of opening a
restaurant, don't do it.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't do it right now.
Wait.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: I know, but
it might never get better.
ANDY RICKER: Professionally,
I think me, like most people
I know in the
industry, we're all
just kind of looking at what
we do well, and work with what
we have and try to
kind of hone in on that
and really maximize whatever we
can out of what we already do.
Most people.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
So you're not going
to be opening a lot
more Pok Poks, probably.
ANDY RICKER: No.
I mean, we've got a
quick service kind
of version of Pok Pok that--
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Smart.
ANDY RICKER:
--we're trying to do
because we think we can keep
it very simple, relatively
low cost, and we can pay
everybody in the place
the same amount, which
is higher than average.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yeah, that's
the way to go these days.
That's why you're seeing so
much fast casual everywhere,
because it's sustainable.
ANDY RICKER: Well, in theory.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
More sustainable.
ANDY RICKER: People keep on
trying to crack the code.
It's proving to
be difficult, so.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: So what else
do you want to talk about?
ANDY RICKER: I don't know.
Maybe we can ask the people
of if there's something
they want to talk about.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Do
you guys have questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So my first job ever--
well, first paycheck
job was as a fishmonger.
So I always love going to
fish markets when I travel.
And I went to Thailand this
February, went to Bangkok,
to the big--
ANDY RICKER: [? Chatuchak. ?]
AUDIENCE: --market.
Yeah, it was amazing.
Do you have any other
recommendations within Thailand
of really cool--
ANDY RICKER: Markets?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, I
mean every major city
has some kind of large market.
In Bangkok, when you go
back, go to Khlong Toei.
That's a real education.
That's a real kind of crazy--
that's the biggest market in--
[? Chatuchak ?] is
this cleaned up,
nice place with
organic food and--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDY RICKER: Oh, you
want to Khlong Toei.
OK.
Khlong Toei like
really down and dirty.
You're wading through effluent
on the floors and stuff.
It's pretty crazy.
It's also full of all
kinds of weird shit,
to be honest with you.
There's lots of
formaldehyde being sprayed,
or whatever they
call that stuff,
formalin getting sprayed on
vegetables and meat and stuff.
So it's a little bit hectic.
If you go up to Chiang Mai--
so go to [? Chatuchak, ?]
then, next time you go.
It's an amazing market.
It really is.
It's beautiful, there's lots
of really good prepared foods
there.
There's a lot of
organic food, like
sustainably-caught seafood,
all this kind of stuff.
It's a really great market.
If you go up to
Chiang Mai, there's
a couple of places
you can visit.
One's called
[INAUDIBLE] Muang Mai,
and that's kind of New
City Market, is what--
it's a big central market.
Kind of like the Khlong
Toei of Chiang Mai,
except for not hectic.
It's very busy, but not hectic.
And that's really
cool because you
can see a lot of the
very, very local stuff.
Anytime you go to any
new part of Thailand,
you want to go to
the morning market,
because you get to see
what the local people are
buying and eating.
And you'll see the same
thing over and over again,
but you'll also see some
very local stuff as well.
So it's just--
I believe there's
a couple of people
that are working on a
whole book on it right now.
The folks from "Eating
Asia", I think,
are working on a
book on markets.
AUDIENCE: You were talking
about the seasonal mushroom
in Thailand.
You were talking about they're
only available for one month.
Which month is that?
ANDY RICKER: Typically
March, April time.
Yeah, it's in the
hot season right now.
AUDIENCE: Is there like
a specific instruction
to pick them?
Like before raining,
after raining?
ANDY RICKER: I've never gone
out and found them in the wild,
but typically it's
during the dry season.
So it's right--
April is typically
very hot, right,
and it rains sporadically.
So it's probably right after
it rains a little bit, I guess.
But they're kind
of like a puffball.
They're round,
they're really dark.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
they taste better
when they're inside the casing.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, yeah.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: What are your
thoughts on Thailand
trying to close down the
street vendors, street markets?
ANDY RICKER: It's
a great question.
So I don't know if
you guys are familiar,
but sometime in the last year,
somebody from the government
announced that they were going
to shut down all the street
vendors in Bangkok, right
after they got named best
street food city in the world.
And so it was kind
of a PR nightmare,
and the cultural minister
popped up and said, no, no,
no no, we're not doing that.
We're just clearing
up some places
and we're going to make it so
that you have to get a permit.
We're going to regulate it.
We're not going to ban it,
we're going to regulate it.
But I think, actually, the
guy who piped up actually
was telling the hidden truth,
is that there is and always has
been this sort of cadre
of elite folks in Bangkok
who feel that it should
be more like Singapore.
They don't like the
dirtiness of it.
To be fair, a lot of the
food that you find on
the street in Thailand,
in Bangkok, especially,
these days, there's problems.
First of all, they clog the
sidewalks so you can't walk.
It's a difficult city
to walk in already,
and they clog the
business areas.
So you can't-- it's very
difficult if you're trying
to do business there.
Also, a lot of the food that
they're selling is crap.
It's just not good.
The bummer of it is,
though, that this
is work for people who are
coming from the country
or they're very poor, and this
is a way for them to make money
and they're serving
people who want it.
So it's a very difficult
thing to balance.
It's already happening.
If you go to Bangkok now, if
you were there two years ago
and you go to Bangkok now,
Sukhumvit is now clear.
There is no vendors
on Sukhumvit at all.
And it used to be from
basically from Soi 1
all the way up to Soi 24,
solid vendors day and night.
Daytime, it was-- not
just food vendors,
but all the vendors are out.
It is weird.
It's really weird.
They've been pushed
onto the side sois
and into doorways and
down little side streets
and stuff like that.
And I think at the
end of the day,
if Bangkok turned
into Singapore,
it would be a terrible shame.
I don't think the Thai people
will allow that to happen.
I don't think that
that's going to happen.
I think that it'll happen
in central business areas
and it'll happen in the
heavily touristed areas,
except for places where they
kind of form food courts
and stuff like that.
But I don't think
it'll go away entirely.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Singapore still
has a good reputation for its--
an excellent reputation.
ANDY RICKER: It's got a
great reputation for food,
but it's all in food
halls and in restaurants.
And I think there
are those in Bangkok
who wish that was how it was.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
ANDY RICKER: And
Singapore, honestly,
the food in Singapore, I think,
has gotten better recently.
Like in the last
10 years, I think
that whole food
court, food hall thing
has made the vendors--
it's gotten competition.
So you got to be good
or else you're not
going to get any business.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Yes,
I've had amazing street
food in Singapore, top notch,
super clean, delicious.
ANDY RICKER: So, yeah, I
miss that vibe walking around
in certain areas,
but in other cases,
it's kind of, what
are you going to do?
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
the US has gotten better
about representation
of regional cuisines?
I've gone to an Isaan restaurant
in Houston and New York
and enjoyed that a lot.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah, as far as
Thai food goes, absolutely.
Over the last 10, especially
the last five years,
there's been a big explosion.
I think that a certain amount
of it has to do with the fact
that younger Thai folks who
either have grown up here
or have come here as
students who are more hip
and in tune with what
people are willing to eat
have finally gone, you
know what, we can do this.
One of the things that you
find, the old guard Thai
restaurant owners, they just--
there was a cultural
thing that's
changing, where
they just culturally
couldn't believe that you as a
farang can eat what they eat.
They look at you and go, no way.
You can't eat spice and
you can't eat funky,
and there's no way.
But that's not really true, I
think, for a couple of reasons.
Number one, we as a
country, as a population,
have gotten a lot more
adventurous, and number two,
we've gotten a lot less white.
And there's is people out
there whose parents are
from another country
or they've grown up
in a home where the food
wasn't Bologna sandwiches.
And they go to school
and go to college
and they're with other
folks from African culture
or southeast Asian culture,
south Asian culture, Middle
Eastern culture,
all mixing together,
and I think there's just
a broader acceptance
because the people who
are spending money on food
now are not lily white anymore.
So I think that has a lot
to do with it as well.
But yeah, as far as Thai food
goes, virtually every city
you go to now, there's
something popping up
that is kind of regional.
You go to Atlanta,
there's Talat.
Guys calling it Talat Market.
Means Market Market.
[LAUGHTER]
And in New York,
especially, when
we opened Pok Pok in New
York five-plus years ago,
there was us and
there were a few--
there were the old school,
like Ayada, [? SriPraPhai, ?]
that kind of thing.
And since we've opened,
there's now probably
eight or 10
different restaurants
that are specializing in Isaan
or northern food or really
high quality central Thai food.
So it's definitely a trend.
AUDIENCE: For those
who maybe aren't
familiar with the different
varieties of Thai food,
what would you say characterizes
each of the regional food
cuisines?
ANDY RICKER: OK.
So there's four basic
regions in Thailand.
The north, northeast,
center, and south.
Starting in the north, a lot of
the food that we do at Pok Pok
is from the north.
The staple rice
there is sticky rice,
and the food tends to be--
because it's landlocked,
mountainous, rivers,
tends to be-- and jungle--
tends to be herbaceous, salty,
spicy but not super spicy,
little elements of sour
that come from leaves
and other kind of fruits aside
from lemons and limes and stuff
like that, and
bitter is a flavor
that features pretty heavily
in northern Thai food.
Isaan, which is the arid
northeast part of Thailand,
where the folks are
mostly Lao and Khmer, food
there tends to be very simple.
They don't have a
lot of resources.
So a lot of fermentation
there, a lot
of relatively spicy things.
So hot and kind of salty tends
to be the predominant flavors,
sour, in Isaan.
Sticky rice is a staple.
They eat a lot of things--
that's a place where
a lot of things
like ant eggs, insects,
a lot of things--
like I said, it's a very arid
region and the resources,
there aren't a lot of resources.
So people get food
where they can.
And over the years,
over the centuries
they've kind of
developed a taste
for things that are
probably not prime meats.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: What
do ant eggs taste like?
ANDY RICKER: Ant eggs
are actually really good.
They're red ant eggs.
They're little, they're white,
and they're about that big.
They kind of pop in your mouth.
They're good.
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Like caviar?
ANDY RICKER: They're not fishy.
CAROLYN ALBURGER:
Anyway, continue.
ANDY RICKER: Then
central Thailand,
where the Thai people, for
the last, I don't know,
500-600 years, that's been
where the seat of power is.
That's where the
royal palace is.
That's where the real
cuisine has really blossomed.
It's also the breadbasket
of the country.
It's where most of the produce
and rice and fruit are grown.
And so the food there tends to
be richer, more sophisticated.
There's access to
the coconut groves
from the south, and quite a
sophisticated cuisine there.
So it tends to be hot,
sour, salty, and sweet,
with sweetness being a little
more prominent there than most
other places in the country.
And then the south, which
is peninsular Thailand
below Bangkok, where the
further south you go,
the more Malaysian
folks get down there.
Sea on both sides.
So lots of seafood, lots
of fish, lots of shellfish.
Coconut groves, so a lot of
really rich coconut curries
down there, and the spiciest
food in the country.
Really the hottest stuff.
They've really developed a taste
for ultra-hot food down there.
A lot of influence from
Malaysia-Indian flavors there.
So I think that's
a broad, that's
very general overview
of what you might find.
AUDIENCE: I have a more general
question about Thai food
and the way you mentioned
Thai as a country,
and the food as the
embodiment of the culture,
the way people
eat it indicates--
what you think makes Thai food's
impact on culture and vise
versa.
How would you define
what is unique about Thai
food and the culture?
ANDY RICKER: Well, I think
these days, probably,
food is the most common
way that Thai culture is
expressed outside of Thailand.
Most people who go
to Thailand have had
some experience with Thai food.
It's kind of the outreach,
the cultural outreach.
It's also-- you've got to
understand that Thailand
is a foodie culture.
They're not foodies, but food is
such a huge part of the culture
there.
It's very rare to go to
any kind of occasion or fun
happening where
food isn't involved.
It's involved in
every single thing.
There's foods that you
eat for special occasions.
There's foods-- it's not
uncommon to go to the beach
and see people in the water
eating while they're swimming.
There's this element of
sanuk, they call it, sanuk.
Thai people, in
any occasion, want
to have this feeling of sanuk.
And having food and
having discourse,
like being with your family.
So I would say, as an outsider
observing Thai culture,
I'd say that probably family is
the most important thing, then
the king, the royal
family-- or then Buddhism,
then the king, and then food
after that, in that order.
So it's hugely
important, and it is
kind of part of the cultural
identity of Thai folks outside
of Thailand.
AUDIENCE: So you've been going
to Thailand for about 30 years,
right?
And not wanting to
fetishize the past
or pretend that changes
isn't a good thing,
is there anything that
you've seen sort of vanish
over that period that
you regret seeing go?
ANDY RICKER: I mean, there is,
from a culinary standpoint,
I think that there's been a
broad acceptance of processed
food.
That's unfortunate
to me, because it's
having an impact on the health
of the people of the country.
Youth culture is kind
of focused on things
that are kind of fast food.
If you watch TV there,
there's lots of ads for KFC
and Pizza Hut and [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that.
People are eating [? CP, ?]
eating a lot of processed foods
these days.
Palate has swung towards
the sweet side of things
and the fatty side of things.
But if you think about
it, it's kind of natural.
It's a natural thing.
When there's more
disposable income,
the people who have
that disposable income
want the things that were out of
reach before, the richer foods,
eating more meat than
vegetables, that kind of thing.
It's inevitable.
But you can still, like I
said before, you can still
find the old ways of cooking.
It's just disappearing, like
anywhere else in the world.
Young folks aren't as interested
in hanging out at the family
kitchen and learning at
the foot of their dad
and then taking
the business over.
And the parents
don't want him to.
The parents want him
to go off to university
and become a doctor or
a lawyer or whatever,
because it's a better life.
So it's just like anywhere
else in the world,
I think, changing.
AUDIENCE: Please tell me if
this is a silly question.
But one of the things that I
noticed when I visited Bangkok
is how a lot of the street
cooking was done with woks
and it was very hot.
And so woks are cooked
at a hot temperature.
ANDY RICKER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious if you have
any tips for people that
live in an apartment
or with the ventilation
that an apartment offers
or the types of stoves that
apartments often have for--
ANDY RICKER: I do, I do.
AUDIENCE: How to deal with it?
ANDY RICKER: Avoid the dishes
that you need a very hot wok
to cook.
[LAUGHTER]
So [INAUDIBLE],, for
instance, you probably
don't want to do that
in your apartment,
or pad see [? ew, ?] something
like that, that really,
to get the really great
taste, you need that really,
really smoking hot.
If you have a balcony,
just go against your condo
association's thing.
Got to get out there
and do it anyway.
But yeah, I mean, look,
anything that's cooked in a wok,
is if you look closely
enough at, has probably got--
if you need a wok to make it,
it's a Chinese-influenced dish.
And a lot of the dishes that
are very, very Thai or very
northern, the original
cooking techniques would
have been boiling, grilling,
steaming, that kind of cooking.
So a lot-- like
curries, you don't
need a wok to make a curry.
You don't need a wok to
make a yam or a salad.
You don't need a wok
to make grilled foods.
You can get away with
just using a nice aluminum
pan that's shaped like a
wok for a lot of stuff.
Or just a regular pot.
So that would be my answer.
Wait till you go home
to your parents' house
and burn up their place.
AUDIENCE: So I have
some in-laws that
are sticky rice farmers in a
village outside of Chiang Rai,
and whenever I eat
with them, the food
is delicious, but so
spicy that I'm literally
sobbing by the second bite.
So I was wondering,
what is your experience
with adjusting or not
adjusting dishes to better suit
American palates,
and how does that
relate to your refusal to
use terms like authenticity
and tradition?
ANDY RICKER: OK, so
there's one of two things
that I'm going to guess
about your situation.
Number one is that your family
really loves spicy food,
and number two, maybe you
don't have a strong tolerance
for spicy food.
AUDIENCE: I get--
maybe the former.
ANDY RICKER: Maybe
the former, yeah.
So heat is a relative term.
And to me, in the north,
the vast majority of people
up there don't eat
things super spicy.
A lot of the dishes that you
have, and you could argue,
well, you're a white guy so
when they see you coming,
they tone it down for you.
But the problem-- the
thing is about that
is there's ways around that.
You go to the restaurant
where the food is pre-made
and just order what
everybody else is having,
and you can get a really
good sense of what it is
that they're making there.
The other thing to
remember about food
in Thailand and eating there,
is that if the food isn't
pre-made, Thai people
have a lot of say
in how their food turns out.
They can tell the vendor, make
it spicy, and tell them exactly
how spicy to make
it, or not spicy.
Or they avoid the
place that's spicy,
or they avoid the
place that's not spicy.
Whereas here, culturally,
we expect the food
to arrive at the table
exactly the way that we
expect it to arrive there.
And a lot of times, unless we
have familiarity with the food,
we lack the vocabulary
to say how we like it.
So this whole thing with five
stars, that has no meaning.
That's literally a
no meaning thing.
All that means that there's
more chili powder goes in.
And there's no standard across--
if you ask 10 restaurateurs
what does five star mean,
they're going to have a
different answer for what
they do to make it
five star chili hot.
So how do I determine the
spice level of the food
that we serve?
I don't make any kind of--
I don't tone it down,
per se, but I might not
make a dish at the
restaurant that's
just ballistically
spicy, or I won't have
all the dishes on the menu be--
I'll have a dish that's
appropriate to be
really, really spicy, and
that's just the way it is.
Like our muu paa kham
waan, or boar collar,
that spicy as fuck, and
that's the way it is.
And I'm sorry if
you don't like it,
you shouldn't have the dish.
That's it.
Just eat lots of
sticky rice with it.
But there's other
things, like, say,
kaeng hang leh, the northern
Thai Burmese pork belly curry.
That's not a spicy dish.
It just isn't.
It is not a spicy dish.
So when it arrives at the
table and it's not spicy,
and people are like, I
need this to be spicy,
it's like, well, sure, here,
have some chili powder.
I don't really know what to
give you to make it spicy
because that's not
a dish that's spicy.
Khao soi, same story, khao soi.
That's a mild dish.
It's not spicy.
It really isn't.
You have to add chili
paste to make it spicy.
[INAUDIBLE] the southern
Thai minced meat
curry that has lots and lots,
that's ballistically hot,
and it wouldn't
taste right unless it
was ballistically hot.
So that's a lot of words
to not give you an answer.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN ALBURGER: Well done.
I think we are finished.
We're out of time, so
thanks everyone for coming.
Thank you so much
for being here.
ANDY RICKER: Yeah.
Pleasure.
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
I think we got some
books to give away, too.